hier bin ich ja wo geht's hoch wie jetzt
wird wieder zurück
ja ich glaube nicht an ein kleiner
beschaulicher lang die höhle siebels
komischen effekt
immer mit der ruhe freundchen rekord
schon wieder ein neues thema hier
anfangen und zwar kann man sich
irgendwie als gast mal bewerben von
mister iz da habe ich auch gemacht es
geht hat sich bewährt geld habe ich eh
schon mal jemand ne na.de v-form
bewerben und dann das ist normal wie
viel werbung er hilft mit seiner website
macht also wir haben diese auch scheiße
wir haben das so gedacht dass wir eine
komplette halt die schnauze
denn wir hatten gedacht dass wir die
komplette show auf wenn ich mir dass wir
erstmals ein paar leute abklappern die
ich leute abklappern sondern leute
einladen gewissen einflussreich mal
haben ein bisschen größer sind weil wir
jetzt nicht sofort jeden einzelnen
kleinen anschreiben wollten und jeden
einladen werden soll müssen vor allem
darum jedem neuen chefs hand sind die
wir ohne nicht rund weil wir uns nicht
auf eher kleinere youtuber verlassen
kann wir letzter mit null abonnenten
ankommt und wir mit dem sky bei dies
austauschen damit wir hier aufnehmen
können als erstes sein dass er die
rausgibt zweite bei mir ist so weil die
privates zweitens weiß man nie wie alt
ist der jetzt vielleicht hat er ja
gelogen ich weiß nicht und da hat man
halt nicht so die versicherung wie wenn
man als wirklich so typen einlädt
derzeit schon so ein bisschen erfahren
als sage ich mal von dem die leute auch
wirklich was hören wollen sie aus den
kommentaren als wert auf themen
beantworten und so und ja deswegen hier
werden denke ich nicht leute wie also
nicht dich zu als zuschauer einladen
vielleicht kommt irgendwann mal so ein
special na ja das wollte jetzt august
und dem jazz oder sahen zu was man aber
muss man da auch noch ein paar dazu
sagen ich kann es relativ nüchtern hier
behaupten
es ist auch das ist auch immer die große
frage die ich mir stelle wenn leute mir
schreiben macht auch mal märz mit seinen
zuschauern
das ist genau das was hier gesagt hat
wie interessant die leute einfach für
jemanden ist klar also mensch ist mensch
mensch ist an sich interessant wenn man
mal von ihm gehört hat oder so dann ist
das noch mal ein stück spannender und es
ist letztlich es ist halt für alle die
zuschauen interessante wenn ich liegt
übrigens im bett könnt ihr auch mal
machen wenn jemand dabei ist von dem wir
schon mal gehört hat den man vielleicht
sogar abonniert hat ersten videos man
vielleicht sogar kurz als dass vor allem
mensch sonst teuer ist richtig vor allem
wenn es um sowas geht wie hier in der
today show wo wir über
welche themen reden weil ja klar jeder
zu jedem thema eine meinung oder naja zu
den meisten thema eine meinung aber die
meinung interessiert euch jetzt ja nicht
unbedingt aber vielleicht interessiert
euch die meinung von jemandem den hier
auch zoe schon verfolgt oder weil von
der bekannteren person halt dann
interessiert an die meinung aber nicht
von irgendjemanden aber wie gesagt als
special können mir gut vorstellen
irgendwann mal machen wie man reinhold
aber deshalb auch davon 200 300 leute
rein kommt eine reihe leute sind
zufrieden
ja das ist es nämlich lieber wenn wir
zum beispiel auch bei einem special des
falls die sache deswegen habe ich das
eher nicht erwähnt jetzt gerade wenn wir
da jetzt sagen wir zehn leute von euch
einladen dann sagen 10.000 andere leute
warum habt ihr mich nicht genau mehrwert
von scheiße genauso wie mit 100 ps wird
genauso aus starken sage ich mal das
dann sich die leute beschweren einmal
geben es wird immer leute geben die
sagen ja voll unfair obwohl eigentlich
alle die gleichen chancen hatten es gibt
immer leute die es dann in anderen nicht
können ist jetzt eigentlich gerade ich
hoffe der raum ist nicht gerade abholzen
jetzt kommt mit sowie das bau ist kaputt
ich muss kurses bauten bringen ich will
nicht alles verlieren was gerade im
inventar wenn ich sterbe halten erzählt
erzählt wir mal wo er bald es ist
nämlich gerade papa sieht irgendwie nach
eurem bald aus dem häuschen
pass bloß auf nicht zerstören was namen
haut und haar und minute selber eine
spitzenkraft weil sonst benutze ich
deine eisen und dass er seine diamanten
es möchte ja nicht ich bin sozial und so
beweist dieses sozial was du nicht
kennst du den beleidigen schaust du dir
wie du kräften ist richtig
ich tue es jetzt ja ich bin deine würde
ihr gefallen
ja das ist sogar mal die höhle wo ich
den spanner gefunden habe aber ich habe
jetzt durch zufall ist direkt unter dem
haus merke ich jetzt erst
oder habe ich erst vorhin bemerkt er
sonst vielleicht nicht das holz lang
machen
das soll schon weil es gerade wieder hin
bauen man doch ich komme hier kurz meine
sache hier einig man kriegt sogar
kartoffeln von mir nun willst und das
sind sogar echte kartoffeln wo bist du
spielen hier unten und bin sozusagen
beim halbwegs sortiert nicht einstellt
kombi zu halo auch wenn es richtig dumm
ist weiter habe ich etwas wertvolles
tier drin parade probleme weil beim
abziehen abbauen
das man so schnell so tot wenn es
richtig machst du wenn du stirbst du von
deinen spitze wo läufst du hin wasser
holen
du denkst auch an nichts das ist brauer
und ob sie damit wasser ab er hat ja nur
lava gefunden nur anfänger bauen ob sie
damit wasser ab außerdem fiel zum
mainstream und tipps das skating gates
said to germany ist total hipster mutter
ich sehe auch aus wie einer kundin die
kamera app store apps apps apps
das meinen zwar nicht aber er wollte
etwas viel besseres geben schon wieder
ich falle auch überall runde beim
herunterfallen kann man wohl wahr dass
ethische ja ok weiterkommen nun
aufpassen da wo läufst du denn da holz
gerade mein haus wieder
ich kriege das aber niemals fertig ich
habe viel zu viel vorgenommen
passau 4 d hier sollte ich denn ich fand
mich gerade am pfosten wo ist das auch
hier war ich noch gar nicht neu ok cool
eigentlich wollte hier schon richtig
episch großen see zeigen den suche ich
gerade der war irgendwo hier aber das
war es auf jeden fall nicht hier hab ich
noch ein paar coole ärzte auch irgendwo
auch genug jetzt egal jetzt noch
obsidian und alles doch ganz auf ihre
obsidian abbauen
guckt da wo ich hin staaten profitieren
dass ihr ungefährlicher da weil diese
serie so tief sind die haben immer die
schlechte eigenschaft dass die darunter
immer noch zehn schichten lava und dann
ist da der tod ist nicht geil ich finde
jetzt gerade aber nicht den weg zurück
dass das so genial gemacht du hast das
aktuelle werk nicht gestorben
was jetzt ist aktuell thema gas bekommen
das heiße thema das man nicht endlos
spielfilm kann ich am einfachsten
zwischen thema machen entwicklung von
youtube youtube bekommen zurzeit
ungefähr nur ein
die hälfte bis ein drittel ihrer aktuell
ihrer normalen upload aufrufe einfach
weil die video seiner startseite nicht
angezeigt werden ich hab den epischen
see gefunden
ja das ist richtig rund und sonne
richtig feuer
das machte die spinne in meinem zuhause
es ist warum spielen etwas was ich finde
ich mir hoch dass lahm hier ging das war
der epischen see also epische sony aber
du hast ihn so genannt
ach ja wo geht's hoch wie jetzt wieder
zurück oder wie ja ich glaube er war ein
netter kleiner beschaulicher irgendwo
nicht lange ja die höhe des übels kurven
schnell ist mexiko alter überall sind
ecken hier ihr müsst grad vielleicht was
spannendes erleben ich brauche nur so
ein bisschen langweilig einmal hier ist
der weg ja wir erleben hier also told
spannenden sachen ja leute die sich dann
beschwert
hilfe irgendwas falsch hier soviel lava
darunter sollen nicht gut
gar nicht schön war ich so viel aber
thema thema thema wir sie noch nicht
wieder in folge ach so das war noch das
thema werden gar nicht geantwortet
irgendwas mit youtube gast bewerbung
einem entwicklung genau wie youtube
entwicklung ja war das weil zwischen
thema inzwischen themen wie ihre haut
raus ich nix aufrufe nein es liegt doch
so dass es total behindert einfach ist
warum muss youtube immer etwas verändern
können sie sich einfach mal so lassen
weil es doch zufrieden veränderung also
ich finde die veränderungen gar nicht
mal so schlecht aber sie können einfach
mal was hinkriegen
ja ich finde es immer es häufig das
irgendwie nicht so wirklich durchdacht
ist oder sich zumindest dann einfach mal
so es wird einfach mal so rausgeworfen
sie sollen und schauen wir mal wie so
entwickelt als google ist ja gewicht
sind auch sehr ganze überlegung an sich
total bescheuert von youtube dass sie
das alles wie sonst netzwerk sag ich mal
aufbauen wollen weil es ist einfach so
wenn man auf youtube startseite ist es
geht liegt man mittlerweile oben sich so
videos von soda-club sachen ich hab
keinen music channel abonniert hat steht
einfach nur ja den emc hat das gezeigt
und das wird bei mir dann ganz oben
angezeigt und wo ich daher gerne meine
videos hätte jede dieser szene hat
irgendwas geleiten das ja das steht da
steht bei mir auch auf dem handy das ist
richtig krass ich muss teilweise
wirklich mit 56 videos runterscrollen
damit ich wieder im video habe wirklich
das einer hochgeladen hat und nicht
irgendwie dargelegt oder davon
hinzugefügt und so das ist richtig
richtung bescheuert er hat meine leiche
nicht mehr auf öffentlich oder jetzt
nicht nur ein beispiel
ja aber das ist einfach nur total blöd
wenn man muss halt wirklich jahre lang
suchen bis man die videos findet die man
auch wirklich sehen will dadurch bisher
gewinnorientiert logischer weise wie ich
jedes unternehmen fasst das quatschen
unternehmen hätte ja und darum sind wir
das ja bei youtube an den werbeeinnahmen
für wollen videos
vor dem logischerweise sind sie daran
interessiert dass möglichst viele videos
aufgerufen werden also möglichst viele
viel werbung abgespielt verdauen wer
darum partner wie es bevorzugt also
videos ohne werbung werden an der suche
natürlich weiter unten gesenkt so dass
das eine veränderung die die google
macht die machen sie nicht damit wie
sich alle beschwerden es gibt hier
weniger views wieso macht ihr das
sondern insgesamt gibt es schon mehr wie
es aber viele leute für den trotzdem
views weil sie einfach an dieses neue
system von youtube nicht mehr angepasst
oder weil eben diese neue startseite ich
meine ganzen vorgeschlagene videos
klickt man vielleicht heute auf dem
video drauf und das wird dann ja wenn da
sich berichtigung ich klicke ich gucke
einfach viel weniger videos seitdem das
alles jetzt sage ich mal so umgestellt
wurde weil mich ich habe keinen bock
zehn jahre lang nach unten scrollen auf
jeden kanal zu gehen und guck mal was
neues ruck ladung klar ich einfach keine
lust oder durchschaue auch viel weniger
wie heißt es ich habe bei 72 100 kanäle
abonniert aber ich habe trotzdem kaum
mehr ich weiß auch nicht wie das
zustande gekommen ist
aber ich sie ist oft gar nicht so
überfüllt weil ich niemanden zur hobby
kids mit oder so die 10 20 videos
hochladen
aber ich habe tatsächlich eigentlich
england aber darüber schon gesprochen
aber ich schaue kaum noch also früher
was soll ich habe youtube aufgemacht
hatte pro tag zehn neue videos ich habe
die alle geschaut alles was ein abo box
war früher ich weiß nicht ob es jemand
von euch noch daran erinnert früher da
gab es war die abo box so das ist alles
nur so vor kleine vorschau video sparen
und zwar so weiß ich nicht so das war
eine horizontale linie und nichts wert
ich alles im moment hat man ja ein video
praktisch prozent geht's ganz weit
runter und damals war das ist nein ich
habe die diamant schaufel gemacht ich
wollte dem schwert machen
oh mann wir sollten erstmal schlafen
glaube ich aber da habe ich halt ich
alles klar und jetzt dunkel statt mich
kurz aus ok berät weiter deutlich aus
damals habe ich echt alle videos
geschaut und mittlerweile schon fast gar
nichts mehr
also ich schon wieder ein ich habe ja
auch zum beispiel leute wie commander
kriege abonniert einfach um auf den
preis jetzt werben
nein einfach um um weil der kommunal
krieger zumindest in der fläche nicht
unbedingt aber in der kommenden saison
kommt es irgendwann irgendwie ein
bisschen einfacher oder überhaupt gaming
hat natürlich irgendwie so ein bisschen
einfluss und ein bisschen gewicht was er
sagt um irgendwie auf dem neuesten stand
zu bleiben was halt deswegen haben soll
in youtube abgeht aber dann ich hoffe
jetzt sogar eine 7 seine videos dann
sich halt neues neues trials wieder
wasser was er da macht und darum und ich
glaube das geht vielen so dass halt
einfach tausender kanäle abonnieren
auch kräfte denen ich gucke nur darum
also ich bin immer dieses ja ich hab ich
habe so und so viele abonnenten ich habe
1000 abonnenten aber nur 20 nur sagen
wir mal machen wir mal größere
dimensionen knapp 30.000 abonnenten sagt
jemand und aber nutzt nur 5000 schauen
meine videos was die anderen sind alle
inaktiv bo als sollen soll man weggehen
wenn sie inaktiv sind es ist mir gar
nicht so sondern die 30.000 abonnenten
sie schauen halt alle nur jedes fünfte
video oder was und einfach weil sich
blätter nicht interessiert alles
zwischendurch ich tausche glas gegen
kohle hat mir jemand kohle gegen klar
sagt mal rechnen
613 ja du kannst in meinem haus tauschen
schau mal rein unten im keller ok ich
finde ich dein haus einfach so man ist
das ist da wo der wald ist den mit ab
heute neue war ok ich will doch kurz zu
ende bringen ist einfach früher war es
so dass es gar nicht so viel content gab
so qualitativ hochwertigen konnte dem
auch gerne mal geschaut hat und heute da
gibt es so viel content auf youtube was
man sich alles was man gerne schauen
würde gerne schaut dass man sich halt
das zu viel geht das manchmal schauen
kann und darum wählt mal sehr genau aus
was man schaut und früher was
selbstverständlich ist alle abonnenten
jedes video geschaut haben oder fast
alle
mittlerweile ist es ein wenig mehr so
und darum sinken die views oder die oder
manche sagen wieso sind meine videos
oder was weiß ich damit zum abschluss
dieses zwischen themas und